هناك اكثر الما من الطلاق ايش هو حيكون
الخيانه
الخيانه الزوجيه تحديدا هي من اكثر الالام
اللي ممكن يتعرض لها الانسان انك انت لما
تعيش مع هذا الانسان
متجرد
مشاركه في نومك مشاركه في اكلك مشاركه في
اهتماماتك في احلامك في طموحاتك في يوم من
الايام تتعرض للخيانه اكيد انها مؤلمه
ومحزنه وبعض الاشخاص يعاني منها وقد يصل
الى مرحله الالم النفسي واذا ما تجاوزها
ممكن يصل لمرحله
مرض نفسي
اصدقاء مربع الرائعين السلام عليكم انا
حاتم النجار وهذا مربع من ثمانيه نصائح
الزوجيه والاسريه المجال اللي يتفق عليه
في الاستراحه صديقاتك في المجالس اهلك
جيرانكم سهل السوشيال ميديا حتى البائع في
بقاله حيكم عندو نصائح ممتازه انا كرجل
اسمع كلام كثير عن الزواج ترى الحريم لازم
كذا وكذا ترى ينفع معهم كذا انتبه ترى ما
يفهم معهم كذا متاكد ان النساء يسمعون
عننا نفس الكلام
المستشار الاسريه والاخصائيه الاجتماعيه
تقول ان التخصص مهم جدا عند الحديث عن هذه
الامور وان النصائح الخاطئه قد تدمر صوتك
فكيف نعيش حياه اسريه وزوجيه متزنه وكيف
نتعامل مع المد الهائل من المحتوى
والمشاهير اللي حتما سيؤثر علينا تقول
ضيفتي ان الامر يبدا من الشخص نفسه اداره
الداخليه لافكاره ومشاعره وثقت عن نفسه ثم
اداره الخارجيه للاخرين والمجتمع فكيف
ننجح في هذه الاداره اصلا الطلاق الخيانه
وامكانيه ان تستمر في حياه زوجيه بعدها
اما اصحابنا عشان عيالي ادخل ضيفتي انها
كذبه كبرى اتمنى ان يعجبكم هذا اللقاء
استمتعوا من اغرب الحالات اللي جتني عميله
اخذت اربع جلسات بدون اي تشخيص
فالجلسه الاولى دخلت تشكر انا سعيده جدا
اني
استشاريه معك اليوم انا سمعت عنك كثير انا
جايه وانا واثقه من هذا الكلام شيء جميل
انه العميل يجي يلمك وعارف من انت واثق
فيك واثق في الخدمه اللي راح تقدمها له
في البدايه العميله كانت تشكي من مشكله
زوجيه مشكله تربويه مع ابنائها المراهقين
لا شك ان المشكلات التي تعرضت لها كانت
قويه جدا انا لا انكر ابدا لكن لاحظت انه
العميله في الجلسه الثانيه عندها نوبه
عاليه من الاكتئاب
فطلبت منها انه نعمل مقياس الاكتئاب
وبعدها خلينا نشوف ايش الموضوع بالضبط
فطبعا ظهر
الدرجه الرابعه اللي هو شديد جدا فبالتالي
انا هنا كخصائيه اجتماعيه مستشاره اسريه
التوجب علي تحويلها الى طبيب النفسي انا
تعاني من مشكله بالتالي هو ممكن يشخصها
بشكل دقيق
يعرف ايش المشكله هل هي مثلا طبيه او ايا
كان هنا انا نقطه كيف اوصل الفكره للعميله
انه انت الان حاليا مشكلاتك الاسريه
مشكلتك الزوجيه مشكلتك مع ابنائك
المراهقين هي مشكله ثانويه ما هي المشكله
الاساسيه فبالتالي كيف الشخص يشخص نفسه
اصلا
نوع مشكلته انا لازم اتوجه الى المختص وهو
يحدد لي مشكلتي بالضبط هل انا راح استمر
معاه او يحولني الى مختص اخر طبعا لما جيت
ابين لها انه عزيزتي عندك
قد يكون عندك الاكتئاب ما نجزم مرض
الاكتئاب ويحتاج انه تتوجهين الى الطبيب
النفسي
بحيث تجلسين معاه وشخص بشكل دقيق هنا طبعا
العميله بكت قالت لا انا ما كنت اتمنى اني
اكون مريضه اكتئاب اتمنى انه يكون مريضه
نفسيه كيف نظره المجتمع انا توقعت انه
مشكلتي اسريه زوجيه تربويه ايا كان طبعا
هنا انا دورك اخصائي ومستشار اسري اني
اطمنها اهديها اعطيها لاسباب كيف تتوجه
الى المختص كيف انه تحمي نفسها من نظره
المجتمع كيف تحمي مثلا حتى من نظره زوجها
لها كمريضه نفسيه مثلا تحتاج الى دواء
طمنتها هديتها اعطيتها الاساسيات كيف
تتعامل مع افراد الاسره كيف تتعامل اذا
النوبه افراد الاسره لازم يكون في دعم
اسري لها يدعمها في حالتها لما تكون هي
مريضه اكتئاب وممكن تجيها النوبه في اي
لحظه من اللحظات خصوصا انها ما مثلا ما هي
موجوده مع طبيب يدرس حالتها ويعطيها
الدواء بالشكل المضبوط
الشاهد هي ارتاحت شوي انقطعت عني بعد
شهرين ارسلت رساله
تفاؤل تشكر انا كنت في ظلام والان انا
اصبحت ارى الحياه وارى العالم ارى استطيع
ان يتناقش مع زوجي يستطيع يعني اتعامل مع
ابنائي استطيع اني احل مشكلاتي بقدر خلينا
نقول بسيط على الاقل فبالتالي انه العميل
يشخص حالته هذه من اكبر المشكلات اللي
ممكن احنا نواجهها خلط بين المشكله
النفسيه والمشكله الاسريه كذلك هذه من
المشكلات اللي احنا لازم كمجتمع نعي فيها
ونفرق ايش المشكله النفسيه وايش المشكله
الاسريه والمين اتوجه لما اعاني من مشكله
بشكل
حتى لما سالنا في التاريخ المرضي هل
الاسره او العائله في احد الاشخاص يعاني
اي نعم اختي مثلا مريضه اكتئاب وتاخذ دواء
وما ابغى اصير زيها هل عانيتي من مشكله
حسيتي في مشكله في مرحله من مراحل حياتك
انك تشعرين بالانتحار اي نعم انا حاولت
مرتين في الانتحار اثناء المراهقه المشكله
قديمه جدا فبالتالي لا هنا لازم نتوقف
ونكون صادقين مع انفسنا
والنظره المجتمعيه عن خلينا نقول المرض
النفسي او حتى لو ما توجه الى عندي مشكله
اسريه او زوجيه او تربويه لازم يكون فيه
وعي انه وين المشكله يكون عندي خلل وين
المشكله اني اطلب العلاج
وهذا دورنا احنا كمختصين نوعي المجتمع
ننورهم نساعدهم في انهم
يسلكون الطريق السليم باذن الله هنا ايش
الفرق بين المرشد الاسري والمرشد النفسي
في فرق كبير انت لما تتعامل مع مشكلات
اسريه اساسها المشكله الاساسيه هي اسريه
مثلا عدم توافق زواجي مشكله تربويه مع
ابنائك المراهقين
اختلاف في وجهات النظر مشكله مثلا خيانه
زوجيه تختلف المشكلات لكن لما احنا نتكلم
عن المشكلات النفسيه اكتئاب اللي هو ثنائي
القطب ممكن عندك شخصيه حديه شخصيه انواع
الشخصيات اللي فيها اضطرابات فبالتالي
احنا لما تجينا مثل هذه الحالات طبعا لا
يمكن انت كخصائي اجتماعي مستشار اسري
تتعامل معاها توجهها للطب النفسي وبالتالي
هو يتعامل معها بما يتوافق مع هذا التخصص
بعض الاشخاص يقولون لا انا بتوجه الى
اخصائي او مستشار اسري ما ابغى اكون ما
ابغى ما ابغى اكون مريض نفسي يخلط هنا
المواضيع بالتالي لا انت تحتاج الى انك
تتوجه الى مثلا معالج نفسي او طبيب نفسي
كثير يجونا من الحالات على فكره مشخصين
انفسهم ومحددينها وهي بتكون لا مشكله اخرى
او مشكله لها جذر يعني مشكله فرعيه ولها
يتغافلون المشكله الاساسيه وهذه كذلك من
المشكلات اللي يعاني منها افراد المجتمع
احس ان الموضوع الكلام عن المواضيع
الاسريه
دائما نحس انه ثقافه عامه يعني اي احد
يقدر يسولف في اي احد يقدر ينصح فيه بعدين
يجون المتخصصين يقول لا هذا مجال تخصص
ولازم تدرس وكذا كيف تشوفين هذا المفارقه
صحيح
بالنهايه انت كمختص انت ما تتبنى فكرك ولا
تتبنى توجهك ولا تتبنى نظريات علميه كيف
ممكن نشات المشكله سواء وطبعا من الاشياء
الصعبه اللي يتعامل معها المستشار الاسري
انت تتعامل مع فرد تتعامل مع داخل هذا
الانسان
بافكاره بمشاعره وتخرج من هذه النفس
البشريه الى المحيط فيها الافراد الاخرين
المجتمع البيئه المحيطه بالتالي انت لازم
كمستشار اسر يتوازن بين هذا الفرد كانسان
عنده مشكلات النفسيه والفكريه واو
وكفرد في وكعضو عذرا كعضو بين افراد
الاسره او حتى في بين او حتى في المستوى
المهني كيف يتعامل معه في علاقاته فهنا
كيف توازن بين هذا الامرين الداخل والخارج
للعميل وهذه من النقاط الرئيسيه اللي ممكن
تحتاج شويه دقه في انه المرشد الاسري يغوص
في هذا النفس البشري ويفهمها بشكل جيد
عشان يعطيها فعلا المخرجات والمعالجات
الجيده متى يحتاج الواحد انه يصل يصل لكم
قبل وقوع المشكله قبل وقوع المشكله بالضبط
دائما حنا نعاني انه يجينا للانسان سواء
رجل او امراه شاب او شابه مراهق او مراهقه
لما تصير المشكله وتتعقد تتعقد تتعقد
يتوجه
طيب انا ليش لما حسيت اني ماني قادر
استطيع انه اشعر في اني غير مرتاح خلني
اقول اشعر اني غير راضي اشعر اني غير سعيد
ليه ما اخذ استشاره واسال وين المشكله
كل ما تعقدت في مشكله ودائما اقولها في
العياده وفي الحالات كل ما تعقدت المشكله
وكانت مده الزمن مده زمنيه للمشكله طويله
كل ما كانت الفتره علاجيه طويله
لكن لما تكون مشكله قصيره لها شهر او الان
حادثه بالتالي كيف اتعامل معاها ممكن في
جلسه واحده ننتهي في جلسه واحده نشخص في
جلسه واحده نحط الخطوط الخطوط الخطه
العلاجيه لكن لما تكون متراكمه متشابكه مع
بعض فيها عدد من الافراد فيها عدد من
السنوات هنا لا
تحتاج الى فعلا انك تحدد الجذر
وتشتغل في بشكل دقيق على معالجه المشكلات
بشكل فعلا تشخيص مو مجرد كلام ما هو مجرد
لا اصبر واتحمل
للاسف الشديد احيانا بعض غير الغير مختصين
خلينا نقول دخلاء المهنه يتعاملون معها
اذا شعر انه ما هو قادر يعطي الخطه
العلاجيه بشكل جيد
ويتبنى نظريه علميه منهجيه بحيث انه هذه
النظريه الفلانيه تستخدم مع هذه المشكلات
وبالتالي انا استخدم هذه الفنيات بناء
عليها انا استخدمت هذه الطريقه ولا هذه
المعالجه اذا شعروا انه في مثلا في مازق
ما يقول لك الا تحمل اصبر
ان شاء الله يعني
اجرك على الله عز وجل واحنا لا ننكر ذلك
انا دائما اقول في العياده تحديدا الاشخاص
متى نصبر
في حاله الاقدار والابتلاءات انا متى اصبر
لما يكون امر وقع وحدث
انما الصبر عند الصدمه الاولى
وبالتالي انا هنا ماجور ماجور امام الله
عز وجل لكن لما تكون عندي مشكله وتحتاج
الى علاج فعلي حقيقي نقول للشخص لا اصبر
واتحمل لا بالنهايه انت هنا كمستشار مؤتمن
امام الله عز وجل كل ما تقدمه في هذه
الجلسه بينك وبين العميل محاسب في امام
الله عز وجل مش مجرد اني انا اقعد واستقبل
الحاله واشوف انا عندي امكانيات وادوات او
ما عندي خلاص اصبر
فبالتالي موضوع بعض الاشخاص حتى ما يتوجه
للمختص ايش بيقول لي يعني يقول لي اصبر
واتحمل وطول بالك صح ولا لا فبالتالي احنا
لا هنا انا جاي ابغى اطلع من الاستشاره او
من العياده او من الجلسه معي ادواتي
ادواتي لما شخصتي المشكله وعرفت كيف
اتعامل مع المشكله وايش هو سبب المشكله
وهذا اللي نطمح له باذن الله تعالى في
الاستشارات الاسريه يعني كيف ثقافه مجتمع
عندنا احنا يعني احس انه يعني انا اول ما
تزوجت من اكثر نصائح اللي جتني حتى من
اهلي انه وابوها لزوجتي طبعا انه خلو
مشاكلكم في بيتكم انه لا يعني لا يطلع برا
الا في المصائب الكبرى يعني يعني مش
هاكلكم حلوها بينكم
بس الشكل المثالي للتعامل مع المشكله في
مستوى بين الزوجين في مستوى الامهات
والاباء لكل طرف في مستوى المعرف الاقارب
بعدين في مستوى الاخصائي النفسي كيف
الترتيب الصحيح بالنسبه لك اول شيء احنا
دائما نقول لما نتكلم عن المشكلات الزوجيه
خصوص المقبله عن الزواج انت لازم تكون
عندك وعي
بالمفهوم الزواجي يكون عندك وعي ايش هي
الحقوق ايش هي الواجبات ايش هي الامور هذه
هذا رقم واحد رقم اثنين لازم تكون دائما
اقول حتى الزواج حتى المتزوجين سواء حديثا
او حتى في ان شاء الله بعد 30 سنه انت
لازم تكون واعي بنفسك واعي بمشاعرك واعي
بافكارك واعي بايجابياتك واعي بسلبياتك
واعي باحتياجاتك ومن ثم اذا عرفت نفسك
بشكل دقيق او خلينا نقول بشكل عام على
الاقل تستطيع انك تدخل الى الطرف الاخر
بعض الاشخاص اصلا هو ما هو فاهم نفسه
ويطلب من الطرف الاخر في انه يفهمك
ولا هو قادر يفهم الطرف الاخر هي مثلا
نقول زوجه هنا لا مشكله انت لازم تفهم
نفسك مثل ما ذكرنا تعرف احتياجاتك ثم
تنطلق للطرف الاخر تعرف ايش هو الشخصيته
مشاعره وهذا الذكاء العاطفي على فكره ايش
افكاره ايش احتياجات وكيف البي احتياجاته
وكيف اطلب منه احتياجاتي
اذا وصلنا الى هذه الوعي خلنا نقول ما هي
ثقافه هو وعي وادراك وتكون مستبصر اكيد
انك بتكون يعني ما راح اقول لك سعيد لان
السعاده هي كلمه مطلقه بتكون على الاقل
وصلت الى مرحله ودايما اقولها
الراحه والطمانينه وهذه اللي حنا نحذف له
طرف الاستشارات
خصوصا الاسريه احنا ما نبغى تكون سعيد
لانه هذا شيء يعني السعاده هي شعور احد
المشاعر فبالتالي انا اطمح انه تكون كل
اسره عندها شويه خلينا نقول في تفاهم في
تقبل في احترام في راحه في اطمئنان في
سلام خلينا نقول هذا المهم هذا الهدف من
الاستشاره او من
المجال الاسري احنا لما نتكلم فيه
الزواج دائما ينقسم الناس بين المتفائل
ومتشائم لمن يحللون الحاله العامه للزواج
في مجتمعنا ففي ناس يحسون انه لا الامور
طيبه والزواج كويس والعوائل كويسه والبيوت
مستوره وساكتين وكذا وفي ناس لا يقولون
الوضع سيء وشوف الطلاق السنه الاولى 70%
مدري كم
ولا تتزوج طبعا في الاخر هذاك يعني من
تحليلك كيف تشوفين الوضع العام للزواج في
مجتمعنا الان
احنا دائما نقول شو طبيعي ان المي ما
يتوجه للعياده الا شخص عنده مشكله
فبالتالي هل انه المجتمع كله يعاني من
مشكلات لا طبعا ودائما احنا نقول الشخص
لما يكون مرتاح وفي امان واطمئنان شيء
طبيعي انه ما يتكلم هو ما يتكلم الا كان
يواجه مشكله هل نعمم انه المجتمع كله
يعانيه لا طبعا لا يعاني هل معنى ذلك انهم
سعداء مطلقا او عندهم استقرار اسري بشكل
مطلق لا طبعا لا بد انه شيء طبيعي اصلا
انه تحدث المشكلات داخل الاسره لكن خلينا
نقول هذه اسره عندها اكثر وعي عندها اكثر
تفهم وعندها اكثر ما عندها تراكمات في
المشكلات تعالج المشكله لما تحدث وبالتالي
تنطلق الى ما بعد
بعض الاسر كذلك عندهم اللي هي قد يكون
المرحله هذه اللي هي بدايه الخمس سنوات
خلينا نقول مستقره لكن وعندهم قدره على
انهم يتعاملون معاها بالشكل الجيد لكن بعد
الخمس سنوات الاولى او العشر سنوات الاولى
من الزواج قد تطرح عليهم مشكلات اخرى ما
هي مشكله زوجيه
اقتصاديه مشكله تربويه مع الابناء ممكن
صار في مشكله طفوله لديهم احد ابنائهم
الاطفال مثلا عندهم مشكله فبالتالي هذه
الضغوط الضغوطات
يخلط الافراد داخل الاسره بين هذه
المشكلات ويعتبرون انه لا الحياه الزوجيه
سيئه او الاسره سيئه فبالتالي نرجع ونقول
مشكله التشخيص الشخص لنفسه ما هي جيده اذا
تعرضت لك مشكله وما تستطيع
ما في مشكله اني اتوجه للمختص ما في مشكله
اني اسال شخص حكيم داخل الاسره او حتى
صديق انا عندي مشكله فلانيه كيف تنصحني
بدون ما ادخل في تفاصيلها لانه لما تدخل
في التفاصيل قد تكون عرضت الخصوصيات
واحنا دائما نقول انه كل ما كانت الاسره
محافظه على خصوصيتها حتى خصوصيه الابناء
حتى خصوصيه الاطفال كل ما كان ذلك اكثر
يعني احترام لهؤلاء الافراد احيانا في بعض
الامهات خلينا نقول طفلي يبكي طفلي ما
اعرف ايش طفلي عنين طفلي انت ما احترمتي
هذا الطفل بالنهايه للطفل يعني انت كام
لازم تتكلمين عنه باحترام وبتقدير امام
الافراد الاخرين المجتمع بانه ما اظهر
عيوب طفلي مثلا هي ممكن بطريقه لا واعي
قاعد تتعرض تعرض انه ابني متعب عشان
يتعاطفون معها خلينا نقول لكن مو هذه
الطريقه الم يتعاطفون معك
حمايه الاسره لانفسهم تطلب وعي وفهم من
انفسهم وادراك
ايش انا احس انه دائما الناس اللي في
بدايه زواجهم يركزون على كيف اقدر اضمن
زواج ناجح من من بدايه الزواج وكيف اختار
وكيف اقبل وكيف ارفض هذه الاشياء بينما
تقولين انت ممكن اول خمس سنين تكون كويسه
بعدين تصير مشاكل
بعد عشر سنين فالى اي درجه تؤثر بدايه
وطريقه الزواج على نجاحها او فشل لا
بالعكس
مشكله مشكلات احيانا بس الاختيار او عدم
التوافق ممكن هم كلهم كويسين لكن ما في
توافق بينهم
طيب انا هنا حدثت عندي مشكله ايش سبب
المشكله اللي بين خلينا نتكلم مشكله زوجيه
ايش هي السبب
ماني متقبل او في نفور لا والله في تقبل
ما في نفور ابدا طيب ايش المشكله ما انت
فاهم الطرف الاخر ايش احتياج الطرف الاخر
لما كل شخص كل زوجه كل زوج يعرف احتياج
الطرف الاخر ويعرف احتياجاته ويتكلم
الحوار دائما اتكلم فيها الحوار هو مفتاح
كل شيء الحوار وليس النقاش لما تتحاور مع
الشخص ويكون لك هدف من هذا الحوار وتطبق
مخرجات هذا الحوار لانه لازم لما تكون
تتكلم مع هذا الطرف الاخر يكون في مخرجات
عليك مهام واجبات تطبقها مو مجرد بس انا
اتكلم اسمع اسمع اسمع وبعدين هذا اللي
عندك يلا مشينا اقلب الصفحه لا
سمع الموضوع الحوار وكذا
نفصل فيها اكثر ايش هو الحوار الجيد وايش
هو النقاش انت قلت فيه نقاش ايش الجديد
وايش السيء
دائما نقول لازم لما تحدد لما تبغى تتحاور
مع شخص تحدد الموضوع مثل حلقتنا اليوم حنا
حددنا موضوع
اذا ما كان في موضوع للحوار معناته انت ما
انت ما عندك هدف لازم يكون في موضوع
للحوار هذا رقم واحد ايش موضوع الحوار رقم
اثنين ايش اهداف الحوار انا لما اتحاور
معك الهدف
رقم ثلاثه ايش وين مكان الحوار والزمن
المكان والزمن مهم يعني تخيل الشخصين
ودائما اقولها يعني متزوجين او حتى مع
ابنائك
في مناسبات تتحاورون عن موضوع لا طبعا او
تتناقشون عن موضوع او تحطوا لكم اهداف لا
طبعا مسافرين في رحله استجمام وتتكلم وهني
حني وكثير من المشاكل الزوجيه
ذكرتني في هذه النقطه تحدث اثناء السفر
هم صافين ذهنيا فاضيين خلينا نقول
فيفتحون الملفات القديمه طب هل هذا وقت
اصلا انك تتحاور مع الطرف وانت رايح رحله
استجمام دافع فيها مبلغ وقدره ماخذ اجازه
من العمل
وبالتالي تعبان عشان تصل الى مرحله انك
تستجم او تاخذ سفره فتفتح ما هو مناسب
تحديد الوقت والزمان جدا مهم
واضح وتخلينا نقول لك توصيات لهذا لهذا
الحوار مهم طيب المخرج خلاص اوكي احنا
نتفق على كذا كذا كذا
عندنا مشكله فلانية كذا كذا كذا فبالتالي
هنا لما تطبق هذه النقاط خلينا نقول هي
خمسه او اربعه خلينا نقول مثلا هي خمسه
نقاط اكيد هنا حققت الحوار الجيد
بعض الاشخاص للاسف الشديد بطريقه لا واعيه
انا اقول ترى كثير من سلوكياتنا تكون
بطريقه لا واعيه
ياخذ من الطرف الاخر الكلام
واحيانا تاخذوا العزه بالاثم في انه
يتجاوب معك وهنا مشكله برضو كيف معنى انه
مثلا مراه او زوج يقول لزوجته انا فيني
كذا كذا فيك فيك اه هذا اللي عندك يعني
انت تشوف اني انا مقصره اها يعني انت تشوف
فلانه افضل مني
اللي ما يتقبل اخطائي انه يسمع مثلا
تكبر المشكله وكثير ترى من المشكلات
الزوجيه تكبر بسبب الحوار لانه ما هو هادف
بس مجرد ابغى اسمع ابغى اعرف ايش هو نظرته
عني وهو كذلك يبغى يعرف ايش نظرتها عنه
فقط ما في هدف ما في مخرج حتى لما تقعد مع
ابنائك وتتكلم معاهم كثير من الاباء يسمع
يسمع وبعدين يصدر الحكم او الام تصدر
التوجيه طب شو الفائده من الكلام
قد يكون الصمت احيانا في بعض الحالات
ودائما اقولها في بعض الجلسات الاستشاريه
قد يكون الصمت افضل
لانك انت يعني
خلينا نقول تتدارك الموقف تتدارك المشكله
وبصمتك فانك ما تفتح على نفسك نوافذ
وجبهات قد تكون ما تدعم
التوافق بينكم او الاستقرار الاسري بينكم
احيانا يكون في طرف يبغى يتحاور وطرف مو
مهتم او حتى ما يقدر اهميه الحوار كيف
يتعامل الطرف اللي يبغى يتحاور
التاثير كيف بمعنى انه لما يكون انا شخص
عندي ما يقبل الحوار خلاص
ما اقدر اجبره انت ما تجبر الاشخاص دائما
احنا نقول كل ما كان لدى اذا ما كان عندك
رغبه
الطرف الاخر ما عنده رغبه انت ما عندك
رغبه انا ما اقدر اسوي شيء مثلا زوجه تبغى
تحاور تتكلم المشكله عند زوجها هو حوار
حوار خلينا نشرب شاي صح كيف تتعامل هذا
الزوجه مع هذا الزوج بطريقه انه
مثل ما ذكر
تك بطريقه غير مباشره بطريقه خلينا نقول
احنا بعض الزوجات خلينا نقول بالقصص
معلش احنا ناخذها من بعيد
ايش تحب مثلا تدخل لا في مدخله هو في
شعوره هو في احتياجه هو ايش تحتاج ايش
رغبتك او ممتاز خلاص بناء على رغبتك انا
حاعمل كذا كذا كذا
دائما تحاول ترمي خلينا نقول لك سواء رجل
او امراه ترمي الكره في ملعبك
ايش تبغى انت ايش رايك في كذا ابدئي يقول
لكن احيانا بعض الاشياء بعض
الحوار يبدا بانه انا احتاج او انا اريد
او او بالتالي الطرف الاخر فسحه في انه
يعبر او يبين لك او يوضح لك بس انك تقول
لشخص عالي ابغى اتكلم معك
ما هي جحيده على فكره
احيانا يكون شهاد ممكن يجيك الله يستر من
هالكلام
فبرضو احيانا نحتاج شويه ذكاء اجتماعي على
ذكاء
عاطفي على فهم على هدوء اكثر على ضبط
انفعال اكثر كل هذه تكون بالوعي والتدرب
والتدرج عليها كذلك
دائما في الزواج هي نصائح مرسله عند عند
الطرفين احيانا افكر انه غالبا انا الحين
تزوجت بطبق اللي انا شفته في بيتي من مثلا
امي وابوي كيف تتعامل مع بعض عاد كل واحد
هو حظه كيف كان كان مسكره الاسره عنده
وبشيل كذا من حولي من اليمين والمشتمل
المجتمع وشوي من السناب شات وشوي من تيك
توك وكذا كيف الطريقه السليمه للشخص
الطبيعي انه يكون تصور صحيح عن كيف يتعامل
مع زوجته انا رجال
لان في احيانا نصائح انه انت رجال لازم
نسوي كذا لان هم الحريم ترى يحبون كذا
فيروح يسويه يلقى لنا خطا او العكس يقول
لا ترى هذا اللي تسوي غلط لازم تسوي كذا
كيف اكون تصور جيد
دائما نقول الحياه الزوجيه هي حياه هي
بصمه لا تتكرر لا يمكن انك انت يعني صوره
نمطيه او الصوره النمطيه عن الحياه
الزوجيه تطبقها في حياتك هي مختلفه ودائما
اذكر ان الرسول عليه افضل الصلاه والسلام
تعامل مع كل زوجه من زوجاته بطريقه واسلوب
مختلف ما كان نفس الطريقه ولا كان نفس
الاسلوب تعامل مع خديجه رضي الله عنها ما
كان بنفس اسلوب تعامل مع عائشه رضي الله
عنها فبالتالي ليش اختلف هو نفس الفرد هو
نفس الانسان في نفس المكان في نفس الزمان
في نفس ما تغير اي اي حقه من حقبه الزمان
ولكن اسلوب تغير وهذه رساله انه نتفكر في
موضوع في موضوع العلاقه الزوجيه وهي ايه
من ايات الله عز وجل
فبالتالي انا كيف اتناغم مع هذا الشخص
انطلاقا من الموده والرحمه كن فعلا عندك
موده لهذا الانسان وعندك رحمه له فبالتالي
يحدث هذا خلينا نقول الانسجام الاحترام
والتقدير
الحياه الاسريه الهانئه بناء لما تكون
العلاقه الزوجيه مستقره راح تكون الحياه
الاسريه كذلك مستقره
وهذا دائما اكثر شيء انصح فيه الاشخاص انك
لا تحاول انك تطبق
النماذج اللي من حولك هي لا هي ما هو
نموذج واحد هي علاقه انسانيه فريده لا
يمكن ان تتكرر ابدا حتى مع دائما نقول
للاشخاص احيانا يقول لك والله في فتره
الملك كان كذا في فتره بدايه الزواج كان
كذا حتى انتم مع انفسكم في لحظات لا يمكن
ان تتكرر مره ثانيه سواء ايجابيه او سلبيه
كذلك فانت لا تتبنى امر وخلاص تكون تبغاه
هو نفسه او تكون يعني
ما عندك المرونه في التعامل مع المواقف
الحياه المختلفه بس كذا احس اني يعني بضيع
اذا يعني
يعني بجد كيف اعرف الدور المثال كذا
سؤال وجميل في هناك في حقوق في واجبات كل
طرف لما وهذا في نظريه الدور نظريه الدور
تقول لك كيف تنظم سلوك الانسان او سلوك
الافراد داخل الاسره كل مكان لدى الافراد
داخل الاسره مهام وواجبات واضحه ومحدده
والشخص قاعد يطبقها
والطرف الاخر قاعد يطبق المهام الواجبات
للطرف الاخر يكون اكثر فيه هناك تناغم وفي
توافق وفي استقرار فبالتالي كل مكان
الحقوق والواجبات احنا دائما نركز عليها
مو هي مثابه انه اجبار ما في شيء بالاجبار
ابدا حتى داخل الحياه الاسريه والحياه
الزوجيه في تفاهم في اتفاق فيه مشاركه فيه
تكامل فيه فبالتالي لكن بشكل عام كاطارته
طيب كيف كذا الحين بكون عايم طيب خلاص
عشان ما نكون نايمين فعلا نوضح الحقوق
ونوضح الواجبات نوضح الاهداف نوضح
الاحتياجات نوضح
عدم الرغبات اللي انا ما احبها تكون صوره
واضحه
وننطلق منها
ودي من جد نفصل فيها لانه احيانا وانا من
فريق الرجال اسمع النصائح الرجال واشوف في
المجتمع وفي تويتر نصائح مع بعض احيانا
ممكن نفس الفعل
فريق يقول لك يعني مثلا
هل في اشياء بسيطه مثلا هل افتح الباب
لامراه ماشيه ولا لا هذه الاشياء التافهه
يعني
وتنسحب على كل الاشياء الاخرى في ناس يقول
لك ايه احترامك للمراه انك تسوي كذا بس
يقول لك لا انا احس كمراه انه اذا سويت
كذا فانت كانك تقولين انا ناقصه مثلا
احيانا بعض المساعدات احيانا بعض التقسيم
المهام احيانا كذا وكذا في ناس مثلا تقول
مشاركه الرجل في المنزل في المهام
المنزليه هذا يحس ان العلاقه اني انا مثلا
اغسل الصحون مع زوجتي في ناس يقولون لا
ترى اذا سويت كذا فهي بتطيح من انت بتطيح
من عين زوجتك انك انت قاعد تسوي مهام
انثويه
فدائما في هذا
الفريقين احس الانسان الطبيعي
بيسمع بدمعه كيف هي الحقوق هذه العيش
الواجبات اللي بعض الناس بديهيه بس ايش هي
عن طريق التعرف خلال الحياه الزوجيه انت
تتعرف اصلا ايش اللي
يريح الطرف الاخر شو يريحك ممكن الطرف
الاخر يطلب منك متطلبات ما تريحك اصلا
اتمنى انكم تتفهمين اتمنى انه تتقبلين
ما يمكن انه نقول خلاص نمشي على خطه واضحه
ورسم معين انه تكون بهذا الطريقه هي مواقف
انت خلال المواقف ينتج السلوك فصعب اني
اقول سلوك لازم يكون بناء على هذا الموقف
لكن انا عندي توجه انه مثلا بين الزوجين
احترام وموده وتقدير شيء طبيعي انه زوج
ممكن يساعد زوجته في انه يشيل لها الاشياء
الثقيله او يفتح لها الباب او ممكن يشيل
عنها طفله او شيء حقيبه الطفل في بعض
المجتمعات يقولون يعني فيه عدم احترام
للزوج بالنهايه طالما ان الزوجين وهذا
المقياس الحقيقي هم مرتاحين وسعداء
بالتالي هذا اهم شيء
اهم شيء انك تكون انت سعيد ومرتاح وراضي
وتقييمك داخل اسرتك حنا مبسوطين ايش يهمني
الكلام الخارجي
طالما انه ما تعديت لا الدين ولا معتقدات
ولا اعرف بشكل عام فالامر يعني في سعه
دائما يقول لا تحجر واسع الامر في ساعه
استمتع ودائما اقول في العياده في الجلسات
هنا والان كل ما طبقت هنا والان وكان عندك
وعي بهذه الكلمه هنا والان وانك تستثمرها
بالشكل الجيد وتعيشها بالشكل الجميل راح
تكون سعيد في حياتك لانك قاعد تغذي عقلك
اللاواعي بصور جميله في حياتك اثناء مواقف
حياتك فبالتالي تكون عندك تفاعل اكثر في
المستقبل فانه ما زال في الحياه يعني جمال
وهذا المفروض انه يكون
واضح اني قاعد يحاول اسحب منك جواب
بس قاعد افهم من كلامك انك تقولي
انه ما في جواب عام يشتغل لكل احد طبعا
وهذا يمكن مشكله السوشيال ميديا بالضبط
رائع انا ضد انه واحد في العلاقات في
العلاقات الانسانيه بشكل عام فما بالك في
العلاقه الاسريه وثم العلاقه الزوجيه انك
تقول واحد زائد واحد يساوي اثنين انا ما
عندي مشكله مثلا على الصعيد المهني في
الاستشارات مثلا مشكله مع زملاء المهنه لا
زملاء المهنه ترى لازم يكون واحد اثنين
ثلاثه الامر واضح
في الصداقه في علاقات الصداقه لا الامر
ترى حتى في الصداقه يعني يكون اكثر وضوح
لكن لما تدخل في الاسره في ام الزوج في ام
الزوجه في اخوان الزوج في اخوات الزوج ترى
الموضوع شويه معقد شويه صح فبالتالي لا
يمكن انك تمشي على نموذج ابدا
العلاقات متشابكه متداخل المواقف متداخله
متشابهه متطلبات بين الافراد حقوق واجبات
فبالتالي الموضوع يعني الاسره يجب ان تكون
يعني
قدر المستطاع افراد داخل الاسره نحمي
اسرنا الصغيره والممتده من الوالدين من
الاجداد الاعمام الاخوال بالتالي لهم حقوق
احنا دائما قدر المستطاع نحافظ عليها وكيف
نتعامل في في العلاقات
الاسريه والعائليه لكن ممكن انا اقول لك
في الصعيد مثل ما ذكرنا قبل شوي مهني
اشياء واضحه جارك عارف ايش حقوقه ايش
واجباتها كيف اتعامل مع صديقك
قليل احيانا تكون مشكله الصداقه لانها
دائما يمشون في هم متماثلين دائما يقول
علاقه ودائما اقولها علاقه الصداقه هي
علاقه تماثليه انت لا يمكن انك تتصدق مع
واحد ما يشبهلك قليل قليل على الاقل خلينا
نقول في الاهتمامات لكن ممكن الزوجين يكون
ما هو متماثلين لانهم هم اصلا يكملون بعض
متكاملين وليس متماثلين تكمله تتشارك معاه
لكن ما تتمثل معه لانه حقوقكم تختلف
واجباتكم تختلف مهامكم تختلف كل كل تكملون
بعض قاعدين شؤون مؤسسه قاعدين تبنون تربون
ابناء
تربونهم
مسؤولياتكم كثيره قد تكون فيها اعباق قد
يكون فيها ارهاق قد تكون مؤلمه قد تكون
مزعجه لكن غالبا علاقه الصداقه لا ممتعه
انت جاي مع هذا الصديق عشان تنبسط وتفرح
وما انت يعني عندك مسؤوليات ولا فيها
واجبات ولا فيها قيود اكيد انك راح يكون
صديقك يعني العلاقه معاه بشكل
مريح خلينا نقول
فبالتالي احنا ما نقدر انه
نقلب العلاقه الزوجيه والاسريه في قالب
معين تختلف من مكان من بيئه من ثقافه من
مجتمع من زمن من اشخاص كلها مختلفه حتى
اصلا ممكن
قدرتك الماليه اليوم تختلف عن قدرتك
الماليه بعد عشر سنوات سواء اجابه او سلبا
فبالتالي لا يمكن ان نقول خلاص امشي بهذا
الطريق
الاطر العامه ممكن في في موضوع كان في احد
تكلمتي عن القوامه والطاعه مثلا كاطار عام
موضوع القوم والطاعه برضو احس واحد من
المواضيع اللي ممكن يساء استخدامها في في
جهه ممكن يفرط في استخدامها من جهه اخرى
كيف تعالجي موضوع القوم والطاعه في
ممارستك
ممتاز احنا دائما لما اتكلم فيها في الشان
الاجتماعي انه بالحقوق واجبات ادوار مهام
مسؤوليات لما اتكلم في الجانب الشرعي
ودائما نقول انت كمختص اسري لازم يكون
عندك اطلاع على الجانب الشرعي الجانب
الثقافي الجانب الاجتماعي بيئه المجتمع
ثقافتهم لازم تكون مطلع على هذه الامور
عشان تنطلق منها فبالتالي انت في الجانب
الشرعي
معروف انه بين علاقه الزوجيه في قوامها
وفي طاعه
القوامه غالبا تكون هي نفقه الزوج
سواء زوج او اب على فكره فبالتالي يقابلها
الطاعه اللي هي الطاعه حنا نقول لما نقول
كلمه طاعه انه خلاص التجرد من من
فكرك او من رغباتك او لا لا يعني انه انت
تطيع ان الزوجه تطيح زوجها او البنت تطيع
والدها او انه تطيع خلينا نقول اخوها مثلا
ان هي تتجرد من انسانيتها او تتجرد من
رغباتها او احتياجاتها لا يعني ذلك هي
بالنهايه كلكم راع وكلهم مسؤول عن رعيته
وكل مكان هذا اكثر تنظيما واكثر ترتيبا
واكثر تهذيبا واكثر احتراما بانه
اصلا المراه لما يكون عندها مشكله لمن
تلجا
من ساندها من عضيدها من اللي يحميها
هذا الانسان اللي هو اب او اخ او ابل
فبالتالي لا يعني انه هذا ينقص او يقلل من
قدر المراه بالعكس هو يرفع من مكانتك يرفع
من شانك هو يداعم لك فبالتالي التاجيج
خلينا نقول ضد هذا المفهومين انه انت مجبر
وانت مجبره
لا يجوز الخوض فيه انا بوجهه نظري انه لا
يجوز لانه اصلا من ثوابتنا الدينيه
والشرعيه لكن احنا لازم نتفهم رقي الاسلام
ورحم الاسلام في انه ينظم الاسره بهذا
الشكل في انه
ليحقق الطمانينه والسلام داخل الاسره
انا دائما اقول كل شخص يتفوه سواء في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي او حتى في
المجالس انت بالنهايه محاسب امام الله عز
وجل
وكانك مخبب احنا لما نتكلم عن التخبيب انك
تهدم اسره تهدم علاقه زوجيه تهدم علاقه
حتى في الموظف مع مرؤوسه حتى مثلا يقول
البنت مع اخوها او البنت مع والدها او ايا
كان فبالتالي وحذر الاسلام من هذا الجانب
فلازم يكون عند الانسان اكثر وعي اكثر
تفهم اكثر
خلينا نقول اتباع للاشياء اللي فيها اكثر
رقي اكثر هدوء اكثر سلام اكثر اطمئنان ليه
انا الحق الموجات اللي فيها
استنزاف او فيها خلينا نقول كثير
غضبي ليه ابتعد عنها واتبع كل ما هو فيه
يعني
فعلا يدعمني او يغذي عقلي ويغذي روحي وغذي
بافكار ايجابيه وخلاق يا ريت تجي مشكله
السوشيال ميديا وسائل التواصل وهو ترى
دائما كل فريق يحسب انه فقط هو الضحيه
بينما يعني دائما يعني في
المتطرفين للذكور في المتطرفين الاناث في
الظالمين الذكور في ما ابغى اساوي طبعا ما
ابغى ادخل في هذا المنطقه الحساس جدا بس
في يعني متطرفين من كل من كل النواحي
كيف تؤثر حسب يعني
خبرتك اتعامل كيف اثرت السوشيال ميديا على
الاستقرار هذا الاسري والزوجي
اشوف انها قد يكون اثرها غير لحظي يعني مو
هاللحظه انا لما اشوف المقطع
اثور غضبا ولا بياججني او شيء لا ابدا هي
اثرها يكون ممتد الى ما بعد طيب انا ليش
اصلا كافرت دائما نكلم الاشخاص نقول انت
انت كشخص لماذا لا تنتقي مشاهداتك لماذا
لا تنتقي
الاشخاص اللي يغذون عقلك بطريقه
ترفع من معنوياتك تحفزك ليش تتابع الاشخاص
اللي يشحنونك شعوريا يشحنونك اجتماعيا
يعني يشحنونك حتى مو فقط ترى على هم لما
يشحنونك على داخل الاسره خلينا نقول مو
فقط على داخل الاسره حتى على مجتمعك على
عاداتك على قيمك على ليه انا اتبع هذا
الموضوع انت تستطيع ان يكون لك فكر تستطيع
ان يكون لك راي تستطيع انك تكون تبدي
اختلافك عن المجتمع لكن بدون شد بدون
خلينا نقول التطرف بدون الاجبار كل شخص
بالنهايه هو حر في انه يتبنى اي فكره من
افكار احنا ما نقدر نمسك العقول ونقولها
لا تفكرين بهذه الطريقه لكن تعاملك مع
الافراد سلوكياتك مع الافراد ومع المجتمع
تحديدا رقيك هذا هو الانعكاسه لك
وانعكاسها بشكل عام للمجتمعك لانك انت فرد
والفرد هو نواه في المجتمع بالتالي انت
تشكل هذا هذا المجتمع بالتالي انت انت
يعني عليك واجبات تجاه هذا المجتمع في انك
تكون فرد فعال
ونرجع نقول انا ليه اتبع اشخاص يشحنوني
ايش الهدف
ليه انا احط نفسي في مجال انه فيه كاسب
وفيه خاسر ليه
بالعكس ليه ما اكون انا داعم
مساند مشارك
متفهم متقبل ليه انا ما اكون شخص بهذا
السلوكيات
ودائما نقول مثل ما ذكرت انه انت قيمه
تشاهد حتى دائما
الاعلام التقليدي او نتابع الافلام
تخيل انت تشوف فيلم اكشن وانت بتروح تنام
ترام مؤلمه الا لما تصحى من النوم وانت
متنكد او ماثره على نفسيتك او ممكن تشاهد
مشاهدات في الحلم وهذا وهذا الواقع
فبالتالي ارفق بنفسك الطف بنفسك
هي في حتى شكل الاسره الطبيعي في بعض
المشاهير عندنا وبرا يعني اظن كل العالم
في هذه الظاهر موجوده اسره رجل وامراه
وابناء بس يعني حياتهم مو طبيعيه وبعيده
جدا عن الحياه الطبيعيه الرتيبه الممله
اللي في ناس موظفين يشتغلون في البيت واكل
وبنام بس لا هذولي عندهم اكشن حفلات اعياد
الميلاد كانها عرس وهدايا كل يوم وشنط
غاليه للاطفال يعني هذا المظاهر هل تفرق
فعلا هل تاثر سلبا على الاسره اللي هو
بالسين شو عقلك رائع سؤالك اذا كان الفرد
ما عنده وعي
اكيد بتاثر هذا رقم واحد بتاثر بشكل مباشر
تاثر بشكل مباشر
اذا كان هذا ما كان عنده وعي بتاثر بشكل
مباشر
لكن اذا كان عنده وعي
بتاثر بشكل غير مباشر واضحه المعادله
كيف بتاثر بشكل غير مباشر بمعنى انه حتاثر
عليك بشكل غير مباشر عالم على المدى
البعيد لانه انت كشخص لما واو جميل انا ما
عندي مع مليت الحياه ممله ما في الهديه
بالقيمه الفلانيه
ما في صفره بالقيمه الفلانيه احنا بنسافر
لمره بالسنه ممكن مرتين مره خلال سنتين
ايش الهديه اللي جتني في نجاحي في ميلادي
في اشياء بسيطه شيء طبيعي اذا كان يعني
متوسط دخل خلينا نقول الفرد السعودي او
متوسط دخل الاسره السعوديه يتراوح بين
15,000 الى 20 الف قلنا هذا متوسط ولا
املك دراسه لذلك ولكن خلينا بشكل عام هي
متوسط بهذا الشكل شخص عنده دخل عشرين الف
وعنده مثلا التزامات ماليه سكن ايجار
تعليم
مصروفات المنزل المصروفات
خلينا نقول المحروقات
الفواتير ايش حيقدر انه يطبق خلينا نقول
مثل هذه الحياه
هل هو النموذج المثالي فانا لما اقول يؤثر
بطريقه غير مباشره على المدى البعيد للشخص
الواعي لانه الا ما يكون في النفس البشريه
انه انا ابغى زي كذا فانا ليش اصلا اتابع
انا ممكن اكون مطلع لا اعني انه لا يمكن
انك تتابع كل مطلع على كل ما يحدث في
المجتمع السيء والجميل لكن لا يكون هو
محتواك او تتبناه
فبالتالي انت اللي خلينا نقول الاشخاص
اللي تتابعهم مقياس بسيط ممكن اي شخص
يجريه بعد ما يسمع الحلقه او يشاهدها
من الاشخاص اللي تتابعهم في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي عشر اشخاص
السبعه اذا كان عندك سبعه
غير هادفين فانت حيؤثرون عليك اذا كان
عندك سبعه غير هادفين يعني 70% فهما
حيؤثرون عليك فانتبه انه يكون عندك اشخاص
من منها اوراق لا يعني انه نلغيهم تماما
بنايهم لمجهودات وهم قاعدين يقدمون لنا
خلينا نقول نكون منصفين التسويق دعايه
اعلان ما يعني ما ننكر مجهوداتهم لكن ما
نتبناهم بانهم اشخاص
نحتذي بهم في في حياتنا تفاصيلنا العاديه
الطبيعيه
نحس مشكله يمكن السناب شات والمحتوى انه
كانه
كانه تدوين يومي لحياه طبيعيه مو كانه
برنامج تلفزيوني لما نشوف احنا برنامج
تلفزيوني انه هذا تمثيل
فلان الفلاني واسمها كذا وولدها كذا بينما
هذا هو هذا نفسه هذا تمثيل هذا كله تمثيل
الحفله تمثيل التصوير تمثيل في حياتها
كلها تمثيل بس كانها حياه طبيعيه فانا
اقارن حياتي بهذا بس ما اقارن حياتي بفيلم
على على التلفزيون لما تسال اي شخص صانع
محتوى خلينا نقول يقول لك لا مو هذه حياتي
لكن انا اظهر بهذا الشكل لاني انا صانع
محتوى
هذا محتواي انت عاجل انت عاجبك عاجبك تبغى
تتابعني تابعني ما تبغى تتابعني بهذه
الطريقه هو يقول لك بضغطه سري بامكانك انك
لا تتابعني حتى احيانا انا بتابع بعض
المشاهير اشوف شو قاعدين ينزلون لما نشوف
يتعرضوا لانتقادات يقول لك من جابك
تتابعني فقط زر ما تقدر تتابعني انت مشغول
فيني
طيب شخص تكلم معك بهذا الطريقه فعلا ليش
تابعه فبالتالي لازم تصل الى مرحله انه
تكون اكثر وعي
تحافظ على مشاعرك تحافظ على عقلك على صفاء
حياتك
وبالنهايه ما نقدر نمنع احد من انه يقدم
اي محتوى طالما انه في جهات معنيه بانه
ترصد الاشياء المخله خلينا نقول ونكون
منصفين حنا ما نقدر نقول للاشخاص لا تظهر
بهذا الشكل
ايه هو اكيد في حدود
المفروض كذا بس في حد مره واسع لانه نصائح
يعني واحده عندها نصائح بتقدمها احد يقدر
يقول لها شيء حتى لو نصائحها في مقياس
المتخصصين تهدم الاسره وكذا يعني مستحيل
اننا نضبط ايش نصائح الصحيحه التي تقال
يعني بالضبط هذه كيف كيف يتعامل معها
الشخص الطبيعي
مثل ما ذكرتكم ما انت مجبور انك تتابع ما
انت مجبور
دور ان احنا كمختصين برضو علينا واجب وانا
اقولها قبل تسجيل وحنا علينا واجب بدنا
نظهر ونتكلم ونوعي وننصح يحتاج شويه وقت
مننا ويحتوي شويه جهد ويحتاج انه برضه
نتخذ الاساليب اللطيفه الجميله في اننا
احنا كمختصين نوصل الرساله نوصل الاهداف
نوصل
القيم نوصل انه كيف تعيش بسلام وكيف تعيش
باطمئنان كيف انت تعالج مشكلاتك كيف تنمي
من قدراتك كيف تحقق من تقديرك لذاتك كيف
تطور من بنائك لذاتك كيف تبني كذلك افراد
اسرتك كل هذه كلها بناءات حنك كمختصين قد
نكون قصرنا انا ما اختلف ما انكر هذا
الشيء وتطلب ترى مجهود يتطلب انك كنت تحضر
محتوى
يعني احنا عشان نجي هذا الحلقه حضرنا ايام
وقعدنا نخطط ومتى نجوا متى نطلع ومتى
يحتاج لها وقت خلينا نقول
احيانا قد نقول هذا زكاه من العلم قد يكون
انه ترى حنا موجودين احتجتونا ترى نحنا
موجودين انا وكل المختصين في المجال
الاسري والاجتماعي والنفسي بالنهايه حنا
نكمل بعض
في مشكلات اسريه سببها نفسي وفي مشكلات
نفسيه سببها اسري عندك مثلا مشكله هو
الادمان جزء مهم من علاج الادمان الدعم
الاسري
مشكله النفسيه جزء مهم من هالدعم الاسري
فبالتالي هي تكامليه لازم انه نوضح
للمجتمع هذا الدور اللي احنا قاعدين نقدمه
الطلاق من اكثر المواضيع صعوبه ما اكثر
الاشياء المحسنه
بس
هل ممكن احيانا الطلاق يكون الحل المناسب
ومتى يكون بدري ومتى يكون مناسب في نظري
ة في الاعداد
مشكله الطلاق
حتى انا يكون الطلاق فعلا ضروره ودائما
نقول للاشخاص اذا انت عالجت المشكله وكثير
عندي ترى في العيادات تجي تقول لك والله
بطلق او يجي الرجل يقول ابغى اطلق زوجتي
بس ماني عارف كيف
طيب عالجت
فعلت حنا وعشان حنا احيانا دائما نقول
مبدا مبدا من مبادئ الخدمه الاجتماعيه
اللي هو ما بتحق تقرير المصير انا لا يمكن
كمختص اقول لك ايوه اطلق او لا تطلق ابدا
لا يمكن ولا مهني وله اخلاقي لكن انا متى
انا مجرد اني اوضح لك الاسباب المشكلات
المعالجات الطريقه قد يكون الطلاق هو احد
الحلول فعلا انا لا انكر لا شك ان الطلاق
مؤلم لكل الطرفين رجل وامراه بعض الاشخاص
يعتقدون ان الرجل لا يتالم الرجل يتالم
ويبكي احيانا خلينا نقول والمراه كذلك
يتالمون بالنهايه موضوع الطلاق ما هو ما
هو سهل ولا هو بسيط
ولكن في نقطه قد تكون
مغيبه عن الاخرين انه هناك اكثر الما من
الطلاق
هناك اكثر الما من الطلاق ايش هو حيكون
الخيانه
الخيانه الزوجيه تحديدا هي من اكثر الالام
اللي ممكن يتعرض لها الانسان انك انت لما
تعيش مع هذا الانسان
متجرد
مشاركه في نومك مشاركه في اكلك مشاركه في
اهتماماتك في احلامك في طموحاتك في يوم من
الايام تتعرض لخيانه طبعا بغض النظر عن
نوع الخيانه طبعا احنا دائما نقول الخيانه
انواع ولكن لما انت تعيش مع شخص خاينك
ودائما اقول للاشخاص ترى هو خان الله عز
وجل قبل لا يخونك لكن انا لما اكون
اندمجت معك اندماج كامل كانسان كفرد ككيان
ومن ثم تعرض لخيانه اكيد انها مؤلمه
ومحزنه وبعض الاشخاص يعاني منها وقد يصل
الى مرحله الالم النفسي واذا ما تجاوزها
ممكن يصل لمرحله
مرض نفسي فانه يشكك من من ذاته وليش انا
صار لي كذا سواء الرجل او امراه احنا ما
نتكلم عنه انه الخيانه من الرجل او
الخيانه لا لا بغض النظر كمفهوم فبالتالي
هذه اصعب المشكلات كذلك تجينا في
الاستشارات مشكله الخيانه الزوجيه وكيف
نتعامل معاها وكيف نعالجها
فعلا هي مؤلمه ودائما نقول اي شخص
تعرض لهذا
الالم اول شيء
بالمناسبه في احيانا بعض الاستشارات تظن
انها تعرضت لخيانه او الرجل ولكن بعد
التشخيص الدقيق هو مجرد اوهام فبالتالي
احنا نتكلم عن اللي فعلا حدثت
وكيف اتخطاها وكيف بالنهايه هي الم خلينا
نقول تشابه الم مع بعض الصدمه
هي في جزء منها كبير من الخذلان هي في جزء
من الاحباط هي جزء من انه الانكسار لا شك
من ذلك لكننا باذن الله تعالى لها معالجات
فانا ليش ربطت انه في اشد من الطلاق لانه
الطلاق هو ظاهر للاخرين كل كل المجتمع
يعرف انه فلان طلق فلانه الله يعينهم الله
يجبرهم الله يخلف عليهم لكن الم الخيانه
ترمي من الالام والمشكلات الزوجيه اللي
غالبا تكون حبيسه مو الكل يعرف عنها وهذا
المفترض على فكره يعني احتراما للعشره
بعض الاشخاص يعتقد ان مجرد ما تعرض
للخيانه خلاص انهارت الحياه لا لها
معالجات ولها اساليب ولها
فنيات نستخدمها ولكنها
درجات ايش عندنا درجات الخيانه
الخيانه الفكريه
يعني انه يتخيل امراه غير زوجته
وهذه كيف تؤثر على الزوجه
خلينا نقول مثلا انه
مو بالضروره تعرفها الزوجه او الزوج لكن
هي من احد انواع الخيانات لكن هل تقارن
الخيانه الفكريه في انه يعرفوا وحده او
انه يكلم وحده او انه خلينا نقول ما نتكلم
عن الزواج عموما
بخيانه جسديه
طبعا لا طبعا لا طبعا نهائيا لا يمكن انها
تتقارن هل تقارن خلينا نقول خيانه مثلا
مكالمات او
علاقه عاطفيه او علاقه عاطفيه او رسائل او
ايا كان بخيانه حقيقيه وفعليه
بالجسديه بعلاقه كامله لا
تكرار مدى الخيانات على فكره وعددها مع
مين وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا لها مقاييس
فبالتالي عشان كذا حنا نقول
انها تختلف ولها مقادير ولها مؤشرات ولها
انواع لا يمكن انه نتعامل مع نفس الخيانه
بنفس الطريقه
ممكن انه تستمر علاقه صحيه او على الاقل
فيها انت دائما تقولين انه
السلام والوئام هذا بعد حصول خيانه من
اعلى درجه اعلى درجه خيار الجسديه مثلا
حصلت بس انه الرجل فرضا فالمراه تقول
بكمل عشان مثلا البيت عشان عيالي هذا
القصه الشهيره ههه
مره انا سويت تغريده في تويتر صابره عشان
سويت تغريد في تويتر صابره على الاولاد
وهو يقول انا صابر عشان الاولاد واخذت
يعني
يعني ريتويت عالي
ما اعرف كم والله ناسيه يمكن العام اخذت
في تويت عالي اخذت لايك عالي اخذت مشاهدات
عاليه فعلا القصه الشهيره ما في شيء اسمه
انا صابر على الاولاد والدليل ودائما
اقولها لما تيجي تقول لي مثلا احد الاخوات
في العياده انا صابره عشان الاولاد بقول
لهم ما في شيء اسمه صابر عشان الاولاد
كثير من المتزوجين الماء لم يرزقهم الله
عز وجل بابنائه وعايشين حياتهم فبالتالي
مقياس ان الطفل او الابناء هم اللي يربطون
علاقه زوجيه نهائيا انت انت في ميثاق غليظ
بينك وبين هذا الانسان فيه عقد وفيه
بالتالي حنا جالسين مع بعض عشان هذا العقد
الغليظ اللي بيننا مو عشان الاولاد طيب هل
ممكن تتجاوز
اذا اذا اذا عولجت بالشكل الجيد انا
اقولها
فرغت وجدانيا ما كبتت تكلمت عن مشاعرها
بكت علقت
ودائما نقول لا يعني انه انت انت تعرضت
لخيانه انه انت المشكله فيك ابدا دائما
مشكله ترى في الشخص الخاين الشخص الخاين
لانه لو انه لو انه فعلا انت فيك مشكله
كان جاء واجهك وجاء احاول انه يعالج
المشكله او ايا كان فبالتالي تستطيع
تستطيع انك تتجاوز هل يبقى اثر طبعا يبقى
اثر انت لما تسوي عمليه جراحيه وتطيب
وتنسى انت لكن يبقى اثر يبقى اثر واتوقع
حتى تعامل الطرف الخائن بعد الاكتشاف اللي
هو اظن انه برضو يفرق كثيرين احنا دائما
انا ما افضل المواجهه على فكره ترى هذا
الموضوع الخيانه ممكن في
الاعدادات لكن ترى موضوع الخيانه لها يعني
معالجات دقيقه
اما اذا طرف اكتشف خيانه الطرف الاخر لا
يواجه الطرف الاخر
لقد لا يكون اصلا في خيانه او قد تكون انت
خيالات او اوهام
لو ممكن تعطيه تلميح وليس تصريح عشان احنا
ما نبغى نكسر الطرف الاخر ما نبغى يصل الى
مرحله انه انا انكشفت اوه انا ما اعرف ايش
نبغيه تراجع بطريقه
يعني هو يتراجع من نفسه
هو يتراجع من نفسه مو انه يتراجع بس عشان
الصوره في العلاقه اذا ما تراجع هو من
نفسه لا فبالتالي
من طرف ضحيه الخيانه يعني ما اكيد
بهذا الاتزان يعني
احيانا فيه ما راح يكون بهذا الاتزان
النفسي اكيد اكيد اتالم من الداخل لكن
خلينا نقول السلوكي
سلوكياته ممكن يضبطها بحد يعني ودائما انا
ما انصح ابدا بالتجسس ابدا لانه اصلا منهي
في الاسلام بالتالي انت ما بني على باطل
فهو باطل شيء ما شاهدته بعينك شيء ما شفته
بعينك
انتبه انك تبحث لكن في الخيانه موجوده اي
نعم موجوده لها معالجه الى معالجه اقدر
اتجاوزها اي نعم اقدر اتجاوزها بتالم ايه
راح اتالم راح يبقى لها اثر بقول لك ايه
راح يبقى لها اثر شيء طبيعي ما احنا
مثاليين ولا احنا خياليين لكن نستطيع اننا
نتجاوز مو عشان الابناء علشان العلاقه
الزوجيه رغبه عشان الابناء وهذا الطرف
الاخر خان
الطرف الثاني فليه كمل ممكن تكون نزوى
ممكن تكون
ابتلاء من الله عز وجل ايا كان السبب ايا
كان نوع السبب
ذنب هو اذنب فيه وتراجع عنه ويعني واستغفر
وتاب الى الله عز وجل الله يقبل التوبه
فبالتالي
ممكن اننا نكمل في هذه الحياه الزوجيه ما
في اي مشكله
بوعي وبدراه وبمعالجه للمشكله
والمرحله وتعدي
انا ما اسخف من المشكله لكن اقول ايه نعم
ممكن انه
لمصلحه ضحيه الخيال انه يكمل اذا عولجت
العلاقه هذا الكلام قاعد تقوله جدا حساسين
وانا ادري انه في ناس الان بتسمعوا بشكل
يعني جدا سلبي وممكن ياخذ عليك بشكل سلبي
وكذا
بس احنا قاعدين نقول لي الطرف اللي حصل
اللي هو كان ضحيه الخيانه من الطرف الاخر
احيانا هو افضل له هو بدون الاولاد وبدون
المجتمع كذا وقد يكون افضل له هو انه يكمل
يدعوه لج بشكل صحيح هي رغبه هي انت انت
انت رغبتك ايش انت رغبتك تكمل
احيانا ايجابيات انك تكمل اكثر من السلبيه
الايجابيات انك تكمل اكثر من السلبيات قد
يكون هذا الشخص فعلا عنده ايجابيات كثيره
ولكنه اذنب خلينا نقول ما راح اقول لك
اخطاء اذنب وارتكب يعني جرم كبير
لكن اذا هو تراجع عن هذا الخطا وما كررها
في المستقبل ولا مره ومرتين وثلاثه بعض
الازواج مثلا تعرض لعدد من الخيانات انا
لما ذكرت لك العدد مهم فلما يتكرر العدد
يتكرر يتكرر لا معناته مشكله انا ما
استطيع اني اكمل لا انا فبالتالي الموضوع
جدا حساس
ولكن هل يتجاوز اي نعم يستطيع ان يتجاوز
لا يعني اول مره اسمع احد يقول ما في شيء
اسمه صابر عشان الاولاد ليش مو هذا واحد
من اسباب الزواج انه نوفر بيها للابناء
اصلا
لما تقول لك انا صابره عشان الاولاد
تقدرين انت تنفصلين وتعيشين انت واولادك
وتوفر لهم حياه كريمه وتعيش مع اولادها
لكن احيانا الخوف من النظره المجتمعيه
في حب خلينا نقول للطرف الاخر فيه حب في
ازواج يحبون زوجاتهم في زوجات يحبون في
زوجات في زوجات يحبون ازواجهم في حب في
تعلق فيه في انقاط ايجابيه كثير في
العلاقه لكن ما هو واعي فيها ما هو مدركها
لكن يعرف انه في اشياء جميله في حياتي
فهذه المقوله احيانا متى يقولونها لما
يتشكى
لما يبغى يعني ياخذ عطف الاخر اللي هو
قاعد يسولف معه او يتكلم معاه لما
يجي احد يقول لك طيب وش مصبرك عليه يعني
خلاص انتهى الموضوع فهي تقول لا عشان
الاولاد ومعرف ولا هو والله عشان كذا لا
هي انا اقول انا ممكن شماعه جميله خلينا
نقول وين المشكله عشان الاولاد ما فيها
بالعكس
فيها بطوله فيها يعني انك انت شخص مضحي
وين المشكله طيب تعال طالما انك انت مضحي
وعندك هذا القدره ليه ما تعيش وتعالج
مشكلاتك وما تكون صابر تكون مستمتع او
خلينا نقول متقبل ودائما اقولها في
استشارات انت ليش ما تتقبل
تقبلك للطرف الاخر ترى جزء من المعالجه
تقبل وليس قبول الشخص عنده سلوكيات عنده
افكار وعنده اخطاء عنده تقبل مو بشرط انك
تكون موافق عليه لكن تتفهم وهذا ترى نوع
من الاحترام انك تحترم الطرف الاخر انه
مختلف وعنده هذه الاشياء ومقدر هذا الشيء
يعني لما قلت اتقبل يعني كذلك
التقدير مقدر يعني عنده هذا الاشكاليات
عنده هذا الاحتياجات عنده لكنه لا يعني
انه يتجاوزك او يتعدى الخطوط الحمراء معاك
طالما هو في دائرته
ولا دخل على دائرتك وين المشكله خلاص وهنا
دائما نقول انا انا في الاستشارات طالما
انه دائره المشكله في دائره الزوج او
دائره الزوجه لا تقحم نفسك في هذه الدائره
خلاص هي ما هي دائرتك ما هي داخله في
دائرتك ولا هي داخله في دائره الاسره خلاص
هذا نوع من انواع التقدير
دائما في مشكله من حلطمه المتزوجين سواء
رجال والنساء انت قاعد تقراي الحلبه بشكل
مختلف تقولين كانها نوع من طلب التعاطف
فكيف تقريبا حلطمه المتزوجين واثرها على
اللي غير متزوجين والى درجه هي فعلا
انا دائما اقول غير متزوجين لا تصدقون
كلامهم
لا تصدقون كلامهم يعني هو بس يجي يقول لك
يعني
سلبي يعني ما راح يقول لك حتى انا يعني في
بدايه ذكرتني في نقطه جميله انا في بدايه
استشاره في بدايه الاستشارات لما دخلت
المجال هذا
كنت اتمنى الفكره اللي يقول لها مثلا
زوجي مسكينه كيف عايشه يعني احيانا
وهذه الممارسه هيك تعطيك مجال انك كيف
تعالج المشكله طيب شنو قاتل ايجابيه شنو
نقاط الايجابيه كذا كذا كذا هل يقارن
النقطه هذه والموقف هذا بهذا الكم الهائل
فبالتالي انا دائما اقول غير متزوج غير
متزوجين لا تصدقون كلامهم يعني اكيد انهم
راح يقول لك انا امس طلعت زوجتي قاعده
تعشيها مثلا او هي ما راح تقول لك ترى انا
امس سويت والله حلل زوجي وحطيت للقهوه
وقعدنا نتقهوى المغرب مثلا او الصباح او
اي وقت يناسبهم شيء طبيعي
فبالتالي
احنا كذلك نقول خلينا نقول متزوجين
انا ما اطلب منك تبين صوره جميله ولا تبين
صوره يعني سيئه
احفظ خصوصيتك
احفظ خصوصيتك بدي اعمل الحلقه مع اسهل من
المدح اكيد يعني مقبول اجتماعيا انه في
رجال جالسين مع بعض واحد يقول اخي الحريم
اقسم بالله ويا الله قلق ودقت علي ومدري
ايش بس مو مقبول اني اقول والله الحمد لله
زوجتي كويسه معاي ومحترمه واحنا حياتنا
الزوجيه سعيده ومتعالفه ما حد يقول كذا
يعني وهذه النقطه هل من المفترض انه احنا
نبرر المجتمع ليه احنا نبرر المجتمع على
فكره ليش نخلي للمجتمع سلطه احنا قاعدين
نعطي المجتمع سلطه علينا والقيود علينا
وبعدين نقول النظره المجتمعيه والافكار
وماعرف ايش المجتمع والمجتمع والمجتمع انت
اللي اعطيتها انت اللي مكنته انت اللي
اعطيتها المفاتيح وفتحت نوافذك
من باب الحسد ممكن
يعني كيف حالك والله الله كذا فتذم
العلاقه الزوجيه او تذم الكلى او هو طبعا
يا ذم عشان يقولون لا احد يحسدنا برضو هذا
مفهوم خاطئ انت ممكن تقول الحمد لله بخير
ونعمه من رب العالمين والله عز وجل احمد
الحمد لله الذي لا يحمد على مكرون سواه
بالنهايه انت ما تقول الحمد لله انا بخير
ونعمه
هذا جزء من انك يعني اعطيت جواب
عام ودائما نقول الاشخاص انت لا تفتح
نوافذ اسرارك للاخرين سواء ايجابيه او
سلبيه الاسرار
لانك انت تعطي مجال للاخر ودائما ترى هذه
مشكله العلاقات مشكلتنا في العلاقات
الاسريه الاجتماعيه
انك تفتح نوى حتى مع اصدقائك تحديدا حتى
في مجال المهني تفتح نوافذ اسرارك وتتكلم
بالنقاط الايجابيه او بعيوبك او باخطائك
او بايجابياتك او بانجازاتك او خلينا نقول
بمصادر دخلك العاليه خلينا نقول احيانا
انك تقولها اول منخفضه بغض النظر ممكن
يحسدك ممكن يشفق عليك ممكن
يشوفك شخص مثلا متغطرس او شخص
ساذج او يقيمك باي تقييم
من نظرته طيب انا ليش اعطني للاخر انه
يقيمني طالما اني انا
عندي حياتي الاسريه الزوجيه عندي حياتي
الاصدقاء عندي حياه المهنيه عندي خلينا
نقول علاقاتي الاجتماعيه لا تدخل الدوائر
في بعض واحنا دائما في الاستشاره نحط نشوف
الدوائر كيف هي متداخله فسبب المشكله اصلا
انك دخلت دوائر حياتك او انت كدور هنا
عندك كدور هنا دور دور دخلتم في بعض نتج
الضغط الهائل عليك من من الاسره من نفسك
من المحيطين الخارجين
هذه كل الاشياء احس يبغى لها اللي اظن
تسمونه انتم ذكاء العاطفي ايش الادوات
الذاتيه اللي تمكنني اني اقدر اطبق كل هذا
الاشياء المفيده سواء مع المجتمع وكذا
طبعا هو في نقطه
احنا دائما تجيني احيانا في الاستشارات
احنا دائما نتعامل في
اللي هو الاداره الداخليه انت كل ما كنت
اعطيك اياها بعجاله لانها موضوعها كبير
الاداره الداخليه للانسان افكارك ومشاعرك
وعقلك اللاواعي وثقتك بنفسك
هذا جانب احيانا تكون عندك مشكله في هذه
الجوانب في اداره الداخليه ما هي مشكله
زوجيه ولا هي مشكله تربويه ولا ولا
فاحنا نشتغل على هذا الجانب
كل ما كان عندك اداره جيده لافكارك
لمشاعرك لعقلك اللاواعي لثقتك بنفسك كل ما
كنت متزن انفعاليا اكثر كنت ما كنت اكثر
كذا عندك سلام هادي ممكن اي شخص يمر عليك
في الشارع يضايقك تقول الله يهديه تضحك
احيانا عندك اداره جيده لذاتك لادارتك
الداخليه
الجانب الاخر الاداره الخارجيه اللي هي
ذكائك العاطفي والذكاء الاجتماعي من
الاشياء المهمه في حياتك انك تمتلكها
ودائما احيانا مشكله كبيره في انه ما عندك
ذكاء اجتماعي ما عندك قدره على التاثير ما
عندك قدره على تفهم ما عندك قدره على
التقبل ما عندك فهم لي
لي اداء وعادات المجتمع لما نتكلم عن
الذكاء الاجتماعي
بالنهايه لما نتكلم باختصار يعني او بشكل
عام لما نتكلم عن الذكاء الاجتماعي هي
السلوكيات التي تتعاطى معاها وتتعامل فيها
في مواقفك بينما الذكاء العاطفي عشان نفرق
بين نقطتين تتكرر الذكاء العاطفي انك تفهم
شعورك وشعور الاخر وبناء عليه ينتج الموقف
بمعنى انه هذا الشخص من الشخصيات خلينا
نقول حساسه مثلا طرف من الاطراف
هو حساس وانا انسان صريح
او انا انسان يعني شويه
انفعالي فبالتالي ممكن اتكلم بسرعه واقول
لك كذا كذا كذا طيب انا انفعالي ليش ما
اضبط انفعالي لانه فلان حساس
شخصيته عاطفي اكثر فممكن انه خلاص بناء
على كذا ما ينتج مني الموقف الفلاني
المواجهه
اذكرنا مثلا مواقف سلبيه سلبيه عنه خلاص
هذا ذكاء عاطفي فهمت شعوره وفهمت شعورك
ووازنت بينهم وانتجت الموقف
الاجتماعي سلوكياتك تعاملاتك اخلاقك
المبادئ القيم الثقافه المعتقدات تكون لبق
تكون محترم يعني مثلا تروح مثلا في احد
المجتمعات ما تخالف ما تخالفهم هذه من
ذكاء الاجتماعي احيانا يقول لك اسير منافق
لا احنا ما نطلب منك انك منافق ابدا ولا
فيها نوع من انواع النفاق هذه لباقه تقبل
للاخر انت قاعد تتقبل وتحترمه فبالتالي
هذا نوع من انواع الاحترام والتقدير
للاخرين ما هو ما هو نفاق اذا كنت تتبناها
بهذا الشكل فعندك مفهوم خاطئ عن الذكاء
الاجتماعي لا انا احترم منفتح على جميع
الثقافات والان لما تشوف مثلا احيانا لما
يجيك مثلا شخص غير سعودي مثلا ويجي يلبس
مثلا خلينا نقول بشت مثال
او يلبس شيء من من معتقدات او قيم او
ثقافه حنا ما نتكلم عن الدين ثقافه
المجتمع مو هذا يحس تحسسك في انه اكثر قرب
لك ت تفرح يعني لك الشيء الكثير لانه
لامسك اجتماعيا اعرف كيف ياثر عليك
اجتماعيا فهذا نوع من الذكاءات انه هو ذكي
اجتماعيا
فبالتالي ذكاء الاجتماعي لما يكون الانسان
واعي فيه ومؤمن فيه ويعرف كيف يطبقه كذلك
الذكاء العاطفي فاهمه واعي بمشاعره ومشاعر
الاخر وعندك اداره داخليه جيده لنفسك
لافكارك لمشاعرك لعقلك اللاواعي لثقتك
بذاتك شيء طبيعي انك بتكون حققت خلينا
نقول اللي دائما نطمح لها السلام
والاطمئنان والهدوء الداخلي
والراحه اللي احنا ما نطلب السعاده احنا
نطلب الراحه
الله يرزقنا جميعا يا رب
تصفي الاداره الخارجيه من جد هذا الحلم
اللي كل احد يحلم ان يكون واذا كنت واعي
واذا كنت واعي وعندك الرغبه لذلك تستطيع
احيانا يؤخذ على المفهوم الاستشارات
الاسريه فقط مشاكل مشاكل لا لا لا
لها بعد اكثر عمق في انه انت اصلا لو عندك
هذه اللي ذكرناها الثلاث اشياء بتكون اكثر
قدره على التعامل في مواقف حياتك في
التعاملاتك مع الاخرين بالنهايه انت فرد
تتعامل مع اشخاص سواء داخل الاسره او خارج
الاسره
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا لك اتمنى زي
موعدتك انه كان اللقاء احسن من التجارب
العالميه السابقه في التلفزيون الراديو
انا دائما عندنا شويه عندنا شويه عزه
الله يعطيك العافيه يعطيك العافيه شكرا
ثقتكم وشكرا استضافتكم الله يعطيكم
العافيه شكرا لكم وشكرا لفريق مربع العظيم
عمل على اعداد هذه الحلقه عبد الكريم
العدواني في التصوير عبد الرحمن العطاس في
التسجيل الصوتيه يوسف ابراهيم في التحرير
محمد الديني عبد الاحد في التلوين عبد
المجيد العطاس الانتاج ايمن خالد وفي
اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نور
السبيعي بيعطيهم العافيه